kawa his father and their friends may
have reached the end of the road
i don't afraid of anything
i don't reflect no fear
no fear water if we die
sorry i say that but we already died
nobody accept us anyway
the iranian migrants have made it to the
coast of northern france but crossing
the channel to england is difficult
and after 27 people drowned trying this
week it's risky too but it's a risk many
are still willing to take
if i die shooting nobody
even think about me one minute
migrants and refugees camp on roadsides
and railway sidings surrounded by the
debris of a life they hoped would be
temporary and now seems endless
they burn anything to keep warm and wait
just do it their shoes tell them
easy to say
the police is right now everywhere and
they don't let us go to
in the water
easily you know they are really secure
in the beach
right now
french police have stepped up patrols
storms have made this a treacherous time
to attempt a crossing assuming you can
afford the 3 300 smugglers are charging
and the inflatable dinghies they use are
small and vulnerable
but the dream doesn't die patrick from
sudan wants to hide in a vehicle using
the ferry i'm going tonight in the car
morning i'll come here sit and sleep
and eat
okay
again tonight i'm gonna go
i i want to go england
from anything dangerous nothing else i'm
go to england
and believe that dream
interior ministers from france germany
belgium the netherlands and european
commission diplomats discuss the
migration crisis but there'll be one
important absence
pretty patel the uk's home secretary has
been disinvited the french asked her not
to come after prime minister boris
johnson tweeted a letter he'd written to
french president emmanuel macron macron
likes neither the migration policy
suggestions nor the twitter tactics and
the dispute shows how little trust
remains between britain and france at a
time when this and humanity are both
sorely needed rory challenge al jazeera
calais